hey everyone de Volo here and today we
are going over probably one of the
funniest fights that released throughout
the year of
2023 of course this is the long awaited
battle between the planet's strongest
isper and probably the strongest being
in fiction tatsumaki versus saitama this
battle here is taken from the entire one
punch man psychic sisters Arc which is
probably going to release in a week from
now on my channel if you guys do want to
peep it earlier though then make sure to
go down and check out my patreon in the
description to get access to the larger
video I make half a week before I
release them here on YouTube most other
videos I usually Chuck them up like a
day or so before I release them here as
well on patreon I can't thank you all
enough for the support on the most
recent one punch man video going over
the monster Association Arc that video
has blown the actual hell up and I
promise you that I'm putting my all into
creating even better quality videos for
one punch man as we move forwards either
way enough of me rambling on subscribe
if you are new around here and push this
video to 3K likes if we do end up
smashing that goal before my planned
release date of the psychic sisters Arc
then I'll drop the next Arc even earlier
botinga into the one punch man world we
find that any moment of utter madness
tatsumaki has confronted the entire Fuki
group and threatened to wipe them from
the face of the planets showing the love
that they have for their leader the Fuki
group demands to know why if they at
least explain it to them then maybe they
can figure out a countermeasure enraged
with their Defiance tataki stly tells
them that it's because of their
stupidity their Leader's life was put in
danger Fuki doesn't need them anymore
and in her eyes all of them are just a
nuisance if they don't decide to leave
now then Tatam Miki threatens that
she'll make sure they can never work
again Fuki screams out for a sister to
stop however the one to grab the Esper's
hand and put a stop to this complete
rage fist was no one other than the bald
King asking what the hell he's doing SAA
tells her that the two sisters are just
like each other this this is going too
far just to lecture
someone meanwhile and after having her
hand hand grabbed by the big man himself
tataki asks if he's de or something as
she just told him to let go t replies
that he's just trying to get her to calm
the actual hell down causing the esper
to throw Slammer through the
association's base looking at the force
being exerted on him Slammer wonderers
if this was the same ability that sent
Jos flying and tells tataki that right
now she's no different powerwise from
Fuki Fuki having heard this screams out
in horror not wanting s Hammer to enrage
her sister anymore just straight up
pissed now t he screams from him to let
go and begins trying to twist the B
man's body much to the spies of the
S-Class hero saitama is able to endure
her attack making a question what in the
world's different about him chilling in
his own strength Dimension sa starts to
notice a subtle Twitch in his muscles
making Fuki think that he's easily able
to withstand her sister's full power
getting up close to him now tatsumaki
remarks that she thought she'd seen him
somewhere before he's the B who's always
chilling with the demon cyborg confused
this to why he's here now now she asks
if he's a part of the Fuki group as well
un concerned for the child trying to
escape his grasp SAA yells out for Fuki
to quickly evacuate everyone out of here
before her sister accidentally kills
them seen how cute Sarma is with Fuki
tataki with a look I'm sure I've never
even seen before questions if that's the
true reason as to why he's here now
taking this question as like what he
means exactly to Fuki So I says that
it's not like he's a mate or companion
or even close friend you know he's just
simply an acquaintance of hers hearing
this news spots a flame within the heart
of habuki and drops her to the floor
completely unconscious looking hella
devious herself tataki asks why he'd get
so desperate just over a simple
acquaintance either way in her eyes she
needs to test his strength levels to
find out if he truly deserves to be
hanging all over for boki like that
which is absolutely crazy man one or Mar
you guys are nuts for chucking that in
there I laugh so damn hard when I first
saw that part this whole part of the
video like so far is just
unrealistically funny and it just gets
even b as we go like each part is even
better and better and better I don't get
a man it's unreal like how continuously
funny it is every situation saamer is in
is like half serious and just not at all
like even here he gets exactly what
she's saying and even gets repulsed at
the idea of it instead he exclaims that
it's hers she's the one dragging him
around all the damn time and just being
in a total pain God I love the look of
like the star eyed Fuki in the
background just glaring at him anyways
anyways anding yourself up the
surroundings all began warping and
twisting to the power increase and tatak
psychic outputs above all of the
residents began freaking out over this
apparent brand new building already
suffering some damning issues in the
control room GPO yells out that the
elevator to get to the lower floors is
broke the other dude notes that some of
the clients were in visitation with one
of the prisoners along with they select
few Heroes who have also been trapped
down the air as the basement starts
twisting even more slowly reaching the
point where everyone might be crushed so
tells tataki to stop treating people
like trash instead and to keep everyone
safe he grabs and ping close to his
chest causing the esper to feel some
sort of way before forcefully jumping
towards this guy taking tataki with him
elsewhere at the exact same time a
random family is seen traveling towards
their new condo at the hero Association
headquarters knowing that the recent
influx of monsters isn't going to stop
anytime soon the father notes that the
35e loan is a small price to pay for
them to live in peace unable to even
fathom how long 35 years is the Sun just
begins getting hyped up over the thought
of receiving signatures from his like
favorite Heroes once they arrive
suddenly a glint of light pierces
through the afternoon Sky confusing the
father who can't even see what it is of
course that sparkle in the sky was none
other than S armor and tataki who end up
crashing and bouncing along the ground
next to the highway tataki confusedly
asks what the hell satam is up to before
launching his body into a violent spin
whipping the cap body down she slams him
into the ground however saitama's grip
holds firm upon her arm a flustered
tataki accuses saitama of being into her
but saam corrects her by stating that he
just doesn't really want her to run away
and Destroy more homes hearing him say
run once more makes tatsumaki explode in
Anger as in her mind why the hell would
she run away from someone weaker than
her letting her hand go now tataki
instantly changes her mood and even
acknowledges saitama's strength saying
that it isn't half bad pulling her hand
up to his forehead she increases his
psychic output just slightly before
flicking the Caped body sending him
flying back into a pile of rubble
looking up saama notices that tataki has
completely lost it and activated her
signature tornado move over in the
battle tataki hurs a boulder directly at
sight armor yet he easily deflects it up
in her attack potency tataki sends a
barrage of Boulders towards him inside
the control center of the hero
Association base a bunch of low class
workers relay in horror that they've
detected AB normal vibrations
approximately 2 km away from the base
over hearing the commotion and knowing
that middle night is still unreachable
and overseeing advisor asks for them to
begin assessing the disaster level based
off the minimal information he's heard
the advisor guesses that they probably
need an S-Class hero and asks if anyone
can be immobilized immediately Outdoors
you know that random family who's trying
to make their way to their new condo
start heading probably the fattest
StraightLine drifts I've ever seen man
is bringing back the saly drift King out
from out of freaking nowhere looking
through his binoculars and somehow still
sitting in his seat while his dad is
doing the craziest Maneuvers they could
notice as the amazing S-Class hero touch
Mari fighting a mysterious opponents of
course the dude flashing from rock to
rock is none other than the Bold Legend
the father who somewhat realizes how
insanely dangerous of a situation this
is right now remarks that they should
probably get away from here fast the kid
though who's wanting so bad to smoke a
family peeg begs for his father to get
him closer as he can almost hear her
voice suddenly a massive Boulder as s
barreling towards the car luckily the sa
manages to save the family by destroying
it in time annoyed he screams out to
tataki that she needs to pay attention
on what's going on around her asking him
why is acting so damn pompous tataki
swells her energy up and sends another
flurry of Boulders while screaming that
she knows what she's doing seeing the
attack hitting his way and figuring that
she's probably not in the greatest of
moods C comes to the conclusion that for
now he'll keep her company in the desert
where no buildings or people are then
eventually she'll wear herself out
having not paid enough attention though
alude accidentally deflects one of
tatsumaki's attacks into the direction
of that same family Vanishing from sight
in an attempt to stop his own deflection
the car is then saved by the small
espert and pulled up into the sky with
her abilities instantly she turns the
situation on S Hummer and jokes that he
needs to pay more attention when
deflecting things Furious he asks the
dumbass [__] what the hell she just
said to him literally Vin popping with
rage tataki screams that she's going to
turn the pathetic baling into a vile of
farming fertilizer dropping the car to
the ground and leaving the family
absolutely Fred with what they just went
through the psychotic esper reactivates
her terrible tornado ability and begins
sending even more pieces of rubble in
the direction of our now fleeing B
curious as to why he's even fleeing now
she charismatically jokes that this is
pathetic there is no way she'd ever be
able to entrust Fuki to someone like him
telling him that he needs to leave and
get the hell away from her s scoffs it
just how bizarre this is all but thinks
all he wants to do right now is go home
with his motivation plummeting tataki
launches a psychic attack that blows off
saitama's jacket not done she follows up
and sends forth a blast that manages to
knock the Caped body off his feet flying
across a random parking lot saama is
then hit by another few energy attacks
that send him hurling miles across the
baren landscape towards the closest city
meanwhile in in City the aass hero
feather is beaten and heavily injured by
a group of random foes one of the gang
members jok that he went a bit wild for
a bit and did did manage to take a few
of their guys down however with the
injuries F's taken in the process
there's no way he can fight any longer
turns out F had only battled this
notorious ironfist gang with the
intentions of freeing a female hostage H
calling him an idiot for getting fool
they ask the hero for any final words
only for the hero to ask about this
random girl's safety scoffing at just
how mentally deficient this hero is the
underling screams out for eica to show
herself turns out that feather already
knew this chick I wonder how many tricks
he knows and was actually being fooled
by her she was never his woman instead
Big Iron the boss of the Iron Fist is
her man stunned and unable to take in
this cruel piece of information fither
can only listen as Erica explains about
the first time she was sent out as a
decoy to distract him from finding the
gang she thanks him for being so dumb he
couldn't pick up on her terrible acting
from the moment he met her while crying
she could see the intent on his face to
fix the situation he truly is a model
hero
yet she could barely even keep herself
from laughing laughing himself now
further notes that she is indeed right
she is one of the worst actors he's ever
met as tears then suddenly begin
dropping from her eyes big Iron the man
barges onto the scene and questions as
to why they're having so much trouble
with a singular rats seeing that he's
already on the verge of collapse Big
Iron threatens to finish the a class off
with a single shot slowly rising to his
feet and mentioning that this is perfect
with no hostage it means that he can
fully let loose he yells out and demands
that Erica watch this this this here
will be his climax as a hero what the
[__] did I just say remixing the entire
scuffle fether is all of a sudden taken
out by a flying caped body who
uncontrollably smashed through the wall
behind him looking at the Burly boys all
standing in front of him sa on all fours
quickly apologizes for the damage but
asks for them to send the Bell to the
lady behind him looking over and seeing
a bunch of guys on the ground he yells
out that someone should probably call an
ambulance for them as everyone here is
in terrible shape jumping up into the
cut out that sa made when he entered the
building the B tells her that it's
dangerous to blast him through a
building tataki though was just like
broh you're the one who ended up
blasting through it ping his head back
and forth between each party because he
doesn't know where to talk to or who to
talk to or who to address the Baldi
screams that it's her fault for
launching him through the sky the group
themselves all just stand there sweating
in fear as they know that standing
behind the Baldi the number two hero
tataki the tornado of Terror has entered
their building
instantly the boss of the gang assumes
fether broke his promise and called the
heroes out here screaming out he tells
his man that a single S-Class hero isn't
strong enough to contend with them sa
tries telling him to chill but the boss
you know pounds down upon the a class
Hero's head only to instantly be
counterattacked by one of saam's basic
punches having watched the boss get sent
into the stratosphere saitam
nonchalantly asks who these guys are
even meant to be rushing forth all of
the ironfist gang attempt to exact
revenge for their boss how however
tataki demands that they all shut it her
and him are already in the middle of a
little something a little while later we
see that those dedly Iron Fist members
have all been taken care of and feather
has regained Consciousness Erica
mentions that the s-classes vanished
just like a storm in the night after
dealing with the enemies slowly making
his own approach feather tries to tell
her that he was never trucked instead
it's probably best they forget
everything about the past so that now
she can be free like she wanted to
unconcerned for feather Erica mentions
that the one who saved her was touch
Mari and she needs to send a letter of
appreciation staring into the distance
fether knows that everything is now
resolved but he feels as if he was hit
by a car knowing that he said this fight
was going to be his climax F makes the
decision to return home and cry himself
to sleep in an attempt to forget this
day ever happened as seen from the
chopper above the disaster level Dragon
monster kins and rat is continuing its
destructive Rampage so far the Eastern
portion of H city is almost was
completely destroyed if this keeps up
then human civilization could possibly
be in danger at least that's exactly how
it feels if you're on the ground
situated like a reporter it's also been
reported that all police firefighters
and heroes who were in the area have
been completely wiped out coming in to
save the day though it's been heavily
reported through online forums that the
goat S-Class hero metal bat is on the
verge of making his appearance in h City
cheering for her brother to make it
there in time we flash over to see a
sweaty metal bat boosting it towards the
monster and complaining about how he's
going to miss out on his precious cat
having kittens cuz how is it even
possible he's the only S-Class hero
available right now mile notes that if
something happens to his cat he'll legit
murk a random civilian sliding into the
monster's line of sight midle calls out
to it and complains that because of this
damn thing arriving All Transport was
shut down and he's already had to run a
freaking Marathon just to get here
however before he even has the
opportunity to exact revenge on this rat
kinon is simply head shot and killed as
collateral damage and the battle between
saam and tatsumaki screaming that he's a
stubborn loser tatsumaki proceeds to
throw saam through another three
buildings coming to a stop at the other
side s tells the isper just to relax man
that the whole reason for coming out
here to start with was to prevent damage
middle B having stood there and watched
this entire altercation and just not in
the mood after sprinting all the way to
the scene decides to turn around and go
back home man wants to watch his kittens
remember how sweet mask was over at that
uh meeting rning the bubbly boys or
whatever Well turns out that the three
buildings T Mari threw Sama through were
directly opposite the building mask was
in noticing how far they have gone from
their original location sa suggest to
tataki that both of them head back
tataki at first seems Cooperative
dropping down and agreeing with him but
after he points out the direction they
should travel she proceeds to grab saam
by his clean shiny bald head and leads
him back to their original location by
running his head into the ground at the
same time looking back while being
dragged so T points out that there's
something behind them breaking into an
inner monologue tataki knows that if
this thing behind them is able to keep
up with them it must be a monster or
some sort of hero turns out the theme
behind them was the Bal banging Legend
Speedos sound Sonic who for some reason
had a feeling that the man being treated
like a rag doll was none other than
sight armmer UNC concerned for the
previous scuffle speed throws a bunch of
his weapons forth in an attempt to
finally end his rival's life these
special ninja shuriken they've actually
been specifically engineered into a home
in version that was track its Target
then explode noticing them tataki nonch
lightly redirects all of the shuriken
back at the ninja catching him
completely by surprise in an instant he
begins dodging each of his own attacks
yet he fails to notice a nearby dog
poping on the floor and accidentally
steps in it losing his balance speed
[__] me man losing his balance speed
curses Sait while simultaneously getting
hit by his own exploding shurikens after
seeing that they're now back at their
initial location saama Breaks Loose from
tat mari's grip astonishing her with his
speed before telling her that she can
feel free to Rampage here annoyed at him
for looking down on her once more tataki
clarifies that she is actually the one
testing Sarma and claims she should go
all out and put him in his place
literally chilling with his hand in his
pocket Sarma then tells her to go all
out on him which once again surprises
her up on the surface Fuki Witnesses
tornadoes along with a multitude of
differing sized Boulders smashing into
and devastating the landscape due to
Tatum maki's increased psychic outp put
she screams out to her sister that this
this is too much and she needs to stop
but is quickly forgotten about as touam
Mari beams saam through the sky over in
the new base King is seen at the
entrance of s's apartment and is
panicking due to the surrounding
catastrophe wondering where scit could
possibly be at a time like this a Bor
Prophet suddenly shows up crashing into
the wall and telling King that he's
currently too busy to play fighting
games with him cuz he's dealing with
someone curious as to who he's fighting
King inquires only to find out that it's
the this little pump squeak called
tataki or something having heard sa make
fun of her tataki then Dives straight in
for a kick but misses and his said
crashes into the wall as well of course
King who just happened to be standing
there and watching this catches a
glimpse of Tatum maki's underwear
stunning him not wanting to give his
composure away King just stands there
looking composed and ready for anything
as Tatam Mari then Glides back towards
the bold man as the intense Showdown
continues to evolve it sends even more
Tremors in the direction of the hero
Association for ear having you know like
felt the Tremors wonder what the hell is
going on looking out the window and
scaring the absolute life out of forte
sa crashes into the wall just above his
room confused he inquires as to why he's
out here prom his s to ask him about how
his injuries are healing continuing to
tell the young hero to stay in beard the
Caped body leaps from the side of the
building back towards the midst of
destruction after seeing the destruction
that his fellow aass hero left to join
for decides to wait a while before his
rematch with him after arriving at the
Sur surface themselves the remnants of
the blizzard group is left Gob smacked
after seeing just how out of control
touch Mary is swooping in over the
C-Class Heroes tajam Mari knows that she
ended up miscalculating the outputed
power of her limit's limit to start with
she was meant to be testing this guy yet
it's all flipped up on its head now up
until now in her life there has never
truly been an opponent that was able to
take her head on apart from obviously
blast in her actuality she was enjoying
this battle as before it she assumed
that the only person capable standing
against her was blast like I just said
needing to bring this pointless show of
strength to an end tataki begins tearing
up the ground and con torting all of the
rubble into two large waves that Clash
into each other upon forming a tunnel
likee structure the esper then collapses
it upon the ant-sized man underneath not
even a fraction of a second later sa
performs an effortlessly unharmed swing
throwing his arm up and dispersing all
of the rubble around him dropping to the
ground exhausted due to the psychic
output of that attack sa jokes that she
really didn't need to go and push
yourself that far and should still have
enough strength to talk with him at the
end of the day snapping at him the es
catches sa and an orb of his psychic
energy however he's so damn heavy that
she's barely able to even pick him up
off the floor asking why she's looking
so grumpy saama reiterates that he isn't
her enemy like he mentioned before it's
just she views the lives of Human
Relationships too Lightly for example
right now she's been stopped by the
power of habuki mere acquaintance
hearing those words and after failing to
send saam in dis SP face tatsumaki loses
Consciousness from overusing her power
dropping to her knees she starts to
remember how blast told her that she
shouldn't either expect someone to come
and save her moments after blast had
saved her in the past tatsumaki
immediately reunited with Fuki in order
to protect her after noticing that she
was being followed by four suomi members
tataki disposed of them before once
again asking fori to come with her the
shock of witnessing her sister's violent
act caused the 5-year-old Fuki to awaken
her psychic power and push Zaki away as
the self-reflection of her continues she
comes to see that it was her that
dragged Fuki to a harsh fate because of
that she now feels like she has the
responsibility to protect her without
relying on anyone else actually crazy
when you think about it the reason
behind tataki wanting to constantly
protect her sister was because she was
the reason she developed powers in the
first place and now feels responsible
for people like possibly coming after
her and stuff Awakening in a bright
Place tataki sees blast standing in the
distance walking up to him she asks if
this is where he's been all along seeing
him leave though she can't help but run
after him and plead for him not to leave
throughout the story so far the only one
to set tatsumaki free was blast due to
this she grow an obsessive excessive
expectation of blast she sought respect
from the one that freed her and needed
someone to guide her on a better Road
catching up to him now tataki just says
that she tried really hard but nothing
ever works out she doesn't want want
everyone to hate and be afraid of her
but if they aren't then things will just
end up how they were before standing
there with tears in her eyes she
questions the top ranking hero about
what she should do when suddenly an even
brighter beam of light begins catching
its way into this already glistening
realm of course she was just waking up
and above her was the gleaming bald King
s Hammer looking down and asking if she
was actually
okay well that brings us to the end of
this like freaking hilarious and honest
a completely unserious battle between
Sarma and tatsumaki some of the moments
throughout this battle had me in
freaking stitches like King scen
tatsumaki's underwear for some reason
just had me absolutely dead I'm old I
shouldn't even be laughing at that kind
of stuff but just him trying to stay
composed is as far too good make sure to
let me know down in the comments section
what your favorite moment throughout the
battle was and what are the fights from
throughout one punch man you'd want to
see me cover in the future either way
like I said push this video to 3,000
likes if you want to get the next part
early or go over and check out my
patreon to see it now massive thanks to
all of my amazing patreons for
supporting there and just to all of the
people who watch my content in general
we've had an absolutely amazing year
with this Channel and I honestly
couldn't be happier with how much
Everything's changed in the last 2 years
before YouTube I was lost in and really
didn't know what to do but now I feel
like I've got a proper purpose so thank
you all for that enough of me rambling
on for now it's been your professional
degenerate deolo and I will see you all
in a bit bye